-Welcome back to "Late Night."
As the Biden presidency
approaches the five-month mark,
not everything is perfect,
but one thing we can say
for sure is
that Biden truly cares
about the American people,
unlike Trump, who only delivered
for himself and his cronies
and who brazenly --
-Oh, here we go again.
-I'm sorry.
What was that?
-Oh, nothing. You were busy
linking arms with Jane Fonda
on the Capitol steps.
Go on.
-[ Sigh ]
I'm sorry, everybody.
This is one of our writers,
Matt Goldich,
and, as you can probably tell,
Matt is conservative.
-Yes, Seth, I'm a conservative
and I'm here to provide
a balanced counterpoint
to one of your unhinged
virtue signal-logues
about how you're going to move
to Canada, unless the next
Major League Baseball
All-Star Game
is played inside a mosque.
[ Laughter ]
-Matt, if you want to provide
your conservative perspective
on the show,
write it up and submit it.
Don't just keep interrupting me.
-Oh, I'm sorry for not providing
a safe space for your views,
Ben & Jerry.
[ Laughter ]
I guess this
intellectual back-and-forth
is a little more difficult
to navigate
than those Hamptons
fundraisers you go to
with Walter Mondale
and Bella Abzug.
[ Laughter ]
-Matt, I'm pretty sure both
of those people are dead.
-Well, thank you, bail reform.
[ Laughter ]
-Matt, I don't even care
that you're interrupting
the show,
as long as you don't show
that long graphics package
that makes it look like
you're one
of the great conservative
luminaries of our time.
-Ah, you must be the one that
lets people know it's time for
"The Conservative Perspective."
[ Somber march plays ]
♪♪
-Oh, I really hate that
so much, buddy.
[ Laughter ]
There's like five or six times
you think it's over
and then, it just keeps going.
Say what you want
about Joe Biden,
but he's delivered
tangible results
for the American people,
while presenting
real solutions --
-Oh, here we go.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. What was that?
-Oh, nothing.
I was just listening to you
do the bidding
of the banking industry
and slobber all
over "Oldman" Sachs,
instead of supporting the
political revolution we need!
-Alright. This is another
one of our writers, Sal Gentile.
And let me guess, Sal.
You're a progressive?
-Uh, yeah, Seth,
I'm a progressive.
I don't know if you've
ever met a real one
at one of those CPAC
conferences you attend
with Milton Friedman
and John McLaughlin.
-I know both of those
people are dead.
-Well, thank you,
private health insurance!
[ Laughter ]
Seth, it's time
for a new voice on your show.
It's time for
"The Progressive Perspective"!
-♪ Fight the power ♪
♪ Fight the power ♪
♪ We've got to fight
the powers that be ♪
♪ As the rhythm's
designed to bounce ♪
♪ What counts is
that the rhyme's ♪
♪ Designed to fill your mind ♪
♪ Now that you've realized
the pride's arrived ♪
♪ We got to pump the stuff
to make ya tough ♪
♪ From the heart,
it's a start, a work of art ♪
♪ To revolutionize, make a
change, nothing strange ♪
♪ People, people,
we are the same ♪
♪ No, we're not the same,
'cause we don't know the game ♪
-And that also sucks.
You can't like keep
cutting back to you,
making people think it's over.
Never mind.
Sal, so let me
get this straight.
You're saying that,
because Joe Biden
isn't a true blue,
dyed-in-the-wool progressive,
that people on the left
should withhold their support
and risk fracturing
the Democratic Party
and sending us back
to the Republican-led Stone Age?
-Uh...
Well, you see --
Alright, look, Seth, I'm not
really that extreme, okay?
-You're not?
-No, of course I support whoever
the Democrat in charge is,
even if it is Joe Biden,
an out-of-touch, old white guy.
I mean, I already work
for one of those.
-Gee, thanks, Sal.
-Talking about you, Seth.
[ Laughter ]
-I know. I know.
-Anyway, I was just hoping
to make a big splash
and parlay the, you know,
this whole thing into a gig,
writing a newsletter that makes
eight figures on Substack.
-What is Substack?
-I don't know!
Nobody knows!
-Sal, you don't need to pretend
you're something you're not.
Just be yourself.
-Really?
Um...
But that's just a guy
who's like super angry
about the Mets all the time.
-Yeah, but aren't they like
good this year?
-For now.
-But the roster's
pretty strong, though.
-They're gonna
[bleep] it up, Seth!
[ Laughter ]
-That's fine.
Just, you know.
-[ Sigh ]
-Just be Sal Gentile.
-Alright, well,
in that case, it's time
for "The Gentile Perspective."
♪♪
♪ Meet the Mets ♪
♪ Step right up
and greet the Mets ♪
♪ Bring your kiddies,
bring your wife ♪
♪ Guaranteed you have
the time of your life ♪
♪ Because the Mets are really ♪
♪ Sockin' the ball ♪
[ Bat cracks ]
♪ Knockin' those home runs ♪
♪ Over the wall ♪
♪ East Side, West Side ♪
♪ Everybody's comin' down ♪
♪ To meet the M-e-t-s, Mets ♪
♪ Of New York ♪
♪ Town ♪
♪♪
-Man, you really love
the Mets, huh?
-They make me want
to die, Seth.
-You know what?
Screw all of you
for wasting our time, Sal.
And screw you too, man.
[ Laughs ]